hi what if fans it's me Peter the voice
of what if I wanted to invite you to
join us and to help out with a huge
event we're putting on it's called live
med aid and it's happening Saturday May
9th what if is bringing together some of
the world's leading doctors scientists
musicians and big thinkers to discuss
collaborate and share ideas on what we
can learn from the virus how to defeat
it and what to expect as we move forward
it's a first of its kind live streamed
event raising money in support of
Doctors Without Borders and frontline
health care workers in the global fight
against kovat 19:00 here's why you need
to tune in we'll be sharing stories of
selflessness from around the world and
tales of perseverance from frontline
health care workers we've got insights
into how to deal with isolation from
astronauts and outer space to monks and
monasteries to scientific researchers in
the South Pole we'll take a closer look
at how global environments have been
affected by economic shutdowns and see
firsthand how the first has begun to
restore itself will be heading to Wuhan
and Italy to learn from their stories
and find out what lies ahead for the
rest of us and we'll be talking to
leading scientists and researchers from
the world over about their unprecedented
collaboration in the hunt for a cure and
about what it will take to prevent this
from happening again those who have
recovered will share stories of
overcoming hardships and families of the
lost will make us understand the price
that many of paid during this time of
turmoil and of course we'll celebrate
the human spirit by hearing from
musicians the world over who remind us
that even in this strange moment in our
history we're not alone you know what if
is one of the lucky teams and that we're
able to keep working mostly from home to
keep bringing you the videos that you
love we saw it as an opportunity to
bring you credible science-based
easy-to-understand information to a
global audience it's searching for
answers
and now we're seeing the unprecedented
collaboration of the scientific
community and we want to bring you that
story too
to let you know that there's hope out
there good things are still happening so
join us on Facebook and YouTube
on Saturday May 9th for a celebration of
hope resilience and human spirit click
the link in the description below to set
a reminder and to get notified when the
show starts see you live on May 9th
[Music]